yeah well it's great we've got Sam Dixon  here our candidate who has just won here  and the reaction here is that obviously  we're very pleased with the result you  know this is the worst defeat for the  conservatives 1832. it was very clear  when we were going on the doorstep that  people are genuinely really concerned  about the cost of living that came up  time and time again they're angry with  the conservatives who have crashed the  economy that there's sleaze that's  engulfed them they're constant bickering  and not being able to get Britain moving  again everyone feels like it's a  constant backlog and they're damaging  our economy and they're damaging  people's prospects and the people of  Chester the city of Chester have given a  huge message to to the conservatives  that they want change and they want a  labor government